(upbeat electronic music)
- Welcome to Ear Biscuits.
I'm Link.
- And I'm Rhett.
This week at the round
table of dim lighting,
we're going to be exploring the question
did our careers just peak?
- We are fresh off of
a tour, a little mini
tour, we went to St. Louis,
Columbus, Washington D.C. and Nashville.
And in Nashville, the
venue was very special
because it was the mother
church of country music,
the Ryman Auditorium.
Yeah so I mean you just mentioned to me
and we translated it into
the question of this episode.
You said that the thought
that crossed your mind,
is this the peak of our career?
- Yeah.
- Yeah I think,
so we wanna talk to you
about the whole tour.
- And I was saying--
- But I'm certain we will
reflect on that specifically.
- P-E-E-K peek.
- Not did our careers just lean over
and look around a corner at us.
- No yes 'cause that would be P-E-E-K.
- Oh that is what you meant.
- Yeah.
Oh you were talking about P-E-A-K.
- Yes.
- Or you talking about
P-I-Q-U-E pique?
- Not that.
What do you mean by P-E-E-K?
You're just, you're being humorous.
- I'm just doing some spelling humor.
- Okay.
- It's one of my favorite
things to do on a podcast
'cause spelling humor
goes really well in the audio.
I mean I always look for
a chance to spell pique
P-I-Q-U-E.
- Three different ways
including that way, okay.
- If your interest is piqued,
just a little grammar lesson.
It's P-I-Q-U-E-D.
It's not P-E-A-K-E-D like it
was the peak of your interest.
- And if I peek around a corner
and that piques your interest,
then that may be a peak moment for you.
- Right.
- Yeah and you know what,
spelling's important.
- So we kinda wanna go through,
- It is!
- Put that on a t-shirt.
- Listen, I watch, do
you watch your kids--
- Spell, no, it sounds quite boring.
- No like, have you ever
gone up behind your kid--
- Hey kid, you mind if I
look over your shoulder
and watch you spell?
- While they write a paper.
- I've read their papers, yeah.
- You've never been
with them when they were
in the process of writing a paper?
Now listen, I can relate to this
because I've become incredibly
dependent on spell-check.
- Yeah.
- But kids these days, man.
- They got it bad.
- They stumble over like the
and it's autocorrected for 'em.
- How else would you spell the?
- T-H-E-E.
- That's also correct.
- T-H-E-A.
T-H-I-Q-U-E.
- Your kids don't know how to spell the?
- That's thique.
- Man.
So we're gonna spell
through a bunch of that,
but one of the things,
you don't have a lot
of time in each town, we
did four, those four dates
over the course of five days.
So it's pretty aggressive but you do find
these little pockets of time
to experience a little sliver
of the locale.
And one of the things that we've noticed
that was that was across
all of these cities,
I think it's something
that's sweeping the nation.
- Sweeping.
- Maybe the world.
Of course, I didn't see them in London
or did I?
No I don't think I did.
- I don't think you did
because there's a bigger
bike culture in London.
- I'm talking about app accessed scooters.
- I mean we are in the
peak, I believe (chuckles)
of scooters scootering
around American cities
and there's quite a
competition going right now.
I mean in one, in a couple of the cities,
we saw four or five different companies.
You got Lime, you got Bird,
you got Lyft gettin' into it,
you got Uber getting into
it and there was like
two other ones I can't remember the names.
- Like Jump, Flip, Skip, Hop.
- Something like that.
- Roller Buddies.
- Roller Buddies doesn't fit on a scooter.
- Two Wheels One Cup I
think was one of them.
- I think it's Two Wheels One Foot.
- That's it, that was it, that's ours.
- Two Wheels No Helmet,
that's what they call me.
(both chuckle)
Because incidentally that's another thing,
anytime, now first of all
you got to download the apps
for each one of these services
and then like the first
time you download the app,
you sign...
- You agree to the terms--
- Agree to a lot of things
and one of the terms is
course you will wear a helmet,
but literally no one on
any scooter at any time
that we saw had a helmet on.
- Well I mean so the when
we were in St. Louis,
I mean we we we went to a
barbecue place and then we went to
the Gateway Arch, which I
believe is 630 feet tall.
- Well that's--
- I looked that up
and then I don't remember
numbers so I'm probably wrong,
but I think I'm right.
- It feels right.
- I looked it up very recently.
Well we were gonna go up
there but we didn't have time
to book a tour.
You can take a frickin'
sideways or arch path elevator
to the top of this thing
but we couldn't do that
so we just walked around the bottom of it
and we're walking around down there
and you got all these pavers
and it's undulating terrain,
just little hills but there are some steps
and there are some steps that
then become undulating terrain
and ramps and as we're walking, it was me,
Rhett and Britton, and
I see these two girls,
they were probably like 15.
And they were careening in front of us
on two of these scooters
and the girl in front
zips by us and then she
turns around and she yells,
"Don't go on the stairs!"
And that drew my eye to her
so I didn't actually see
what happened but you did.
- Well the way that the terrain was set up
is there was a blind spot essentially
so from your perspective it just looked
you were gonna continue on straight ground
but really there was like a three,
maybe two or three step drop.
- Of concrete.
- Yeah and the steps were
such that the further left you were,
the more steps there were to go down
and she just happened to
choose a line that was two
or three steps, like two
or three feet to the left
and it would have been five or six steps.
Anyway.
- Did she take flight?
- Well like you said, her
friend said at the last minute,
"Don't go off there," or whatever,
and that was exactly
the wrong thing to say
because she basically
dismounted in the air
and the scooter landed
really, really hard.
She actually landed on her feet.
It could have been really, really ugly.
- And she landed on her feet
and was like immediately like
plop plop plop plop plop like running
in a very awkward fashion.
She could have hit her head
on the concrete and died, man.
- We could have witnessed a death.
- Well I could have witnessed
her friend witnessing a death
'cause I was looking at the wrong girl.
- Well and that's the main
thing that I'm thinking
the whole time I'm on there,
they go like 20 miles per hour
and faster than that if
you're going downhill
and the wheels are relatively small.
There's not necessarily,
you're supposed to be riding
in bike lanes when possible
but most American cities
are not very bike-friendly so--
- Right.
- There's very few bike lanes.
- [Link] A lot of people
on sidewalks.
- People don't know where
to go, they go on the sidewalks.
When they're in the street,
there might be potholes.
People don't have good balance,
people aren't wearing helmets
and so there's this crazy
thing that's happening
where all these companies are competing
against each other to
try to win this market.
But at the same time,
people are getting hurt.
- Well when we were in Austin,
there was this makeup woman
and we happened to start talking to her
about the scooters 'cause
we saw 'em around Austin
and she said, yeah, my husband was on one
and he went off a curb and
fell over and hurt his leg,
and really badly, he was in a lot of pain
and the paramedics show
up and after awhile,
they were like you're okay, just go home.
And he went home that night and he woke up
in excruciating pain
and she said that he was
in so much pain that he
started to go into shock,
and so she took him to the emergency room
and he had broken his femur.
On a freakin' scooter, guys.
- Yeah.
- And the helmet doesn't
protect the femur last time I checked.
- Well if you get a femur helmet.
- That's what we need so Two
Wheels One Foot is gonna,
we're gonna figure out a
way to attach the helmet
to the scooter and also
have like femur pads.
- Right.
- I mean you can really
get hurt because you think
you can ride a scooter
but you don't realize how
fast these things can go
and also you're tempted to
just steer like left, right,
left, right, inky inky inky
but you really should steer by leaning.
- You need to be using your body weight.
- You gotta be using your body weight
but that's not immediately intuitive
and if you start doing
that then you're doing
the shaky shaky shaky thing
and then you're like going,
you're careening out of control.
- And people are, locals hate
these things, I mean so--
- They have to.
- When we were in Nashville,
by that point, Britton's
friends had showed up.
Jenna was with us at
the time so it was like,
there was six of us in a
little pod going down--
- The street.
- Basically the main drag
in Nashville and as we
continued going down,
we started realizing this
has almost become a highway.
People are turning off of
this to get on the interstate.
There's only a few stop lights.
There's no bike lane.
We're right up, we're
going across a bridge
and the six of us in a line
are kinda taking up the lane
and people are just laying on
their horns and locals hate us
and they should.
(Link mimics horn honking)
- But we were doing the right thing
because you're not supposed
to be on the sidewalk,
you're supposed to be like a bike.
But they were just laying on the horn,
I guess it was because
some of us were waggling.
- It goes beyond that
though because I think what
they're trying to do is they're
trying to say don't be here.
Go on a less busy street.
Wear a freaking helmet.
And we were talking to--
- Go back to whatever town
you're from--
- Talking to Britton's friends
and apparently in Raleigh, North Carolina,
they've gotten rid of all of 'em.
- Oh really?
- They've just gotten
rid of all the scooters
is what we were told, I haven't
been there to confirm this.
Because they couldn't figure
out how to regulate them
and then the companies were like screw it,
we're not gonna be a part of this.
It just don't know
where this is gonna land
because people are getting hurt
and they're gonna continue to get hurt.
Personally, I love it.
- When we were--
- I absolutely love it.
- Yeah so when we were in Columbus,
I looked out my hotel window
and I saw a couple people.
We were downtown by the river
and there's nice river walks
on either side of it and I
saw some people with scooters,
I was like (snaps fingers) bingo.
We're gonna do it 'cause we
didn't do it in St. Louis.
I just saw that girl
almost eat it and then,
the next morning, here I am
still thinking it's a great idea
and you know what, it was.
- Oh it's so much fun.
- It was fun.
I mean when you're not just
going on the surface streets
like a downtown area
with a lot of traffic,
but you're on a dedicated path
and a relatively fresh one
that doesn't have a
bunch of treachery to it,
that was fun, man, the weather was great.
- Yeah.
- It was beautiful.
It was a highlight of the
trip was scooting around, man.
Yay!
Woo, woo!
- Being off of the road,
I would say that being
on a not busy road or
being on like a park path,
park path, that is peak scooter terrain.
- But you know what, I think
I'm gonna start traveling
with a helmet.
Why are you laughing?
I got to get a little helmet, man.
You laugh now.
But you're not gonna laugh
when you don't remember how
to laugh 'cause you hit your head.
- There's something about
being on a scooter though
that makes me feel, because
my feet are so close
to the ground already, I
feel like I can just jump
out of any situation, any
danger and just immediately jump
and be standing up whereas a motorcycle,
you're going a lot faster--
- Yeah.
Your feet are real close to
the ground on a motorcycle too.
- But you can't just
walk off of a motorcycle.
- If you ride in a side saddle you can.
- Yeah I don't ride my
motorcycle side saddle anymore.
- How do you ride your horse, side saddle?
- Backwards.
I don't want anybody sneakin' up on me.
- I ride my horses backwards.
(Rhett chuckles)
(Link chuckles)
So I don't know what the future
of scootering is gonna be
but they can't tether
the helmets to the thing
because then that's a hazard.
- Lice.
- Oh lice too.
- Yeah that's a lice hazard.
Is that what you mean by that?
- No I mean if there's a string, a tether,
so that people won't walk
away with the helmets.
I think you need a helmet sharing app.
- Same company, different company?
- Different company.
- We should do the helmet share.
- So you're gonna have
to walk to the helmet
and then the problem
people would be scootering
to the helmets.
- No you gotta sign in, no no
it's gotta be the same company
and you can't, it's like
one of those things,
after you get a few DUIs
you can't start a car
without breathing into
it, you have to step on.
You have to hit--
- You gotta bonk your head.
- You gotta head butt the
scooter with the helmet
in order to get it going.
- Or just be willing to head
butt the scooter really hard
without a helmet to make it seem like--
- I think if they had a helmet
that was like a zip tie,
not zip tie but like a zip
line, like it comes out
from the handlebars and
then you're kinda like
loosely tethered to the thing.
- It's kinda like--
- That sounds like it might
be more dangerous.
- Kinda like it's got
a narrow roof on it.
It's like, have you ever seen those bikes
that would have like a shell on 'em?
- Yeah.
- Like an aerodynamic shell,
have one of those come
off the handlebars, joop,
goes over your whole head.
- Then it's just a little car.
(Link chuckles)
That's not fun, you don't
feel the breeze anymore.
I wanna feel the breeze,
that's half of it.
- Okay.
- Anyway,
y'all gotta figure that out.
And I don't know who's
gonna win this but--
- Yeah.
- I don't know if
I would invest in,
my gut is that this is not sustainable.
But if it ends up being sustainable--
- I think it is.
- My gut says that now that
Lyft and apparently Uber
is in this game, I feel like
they're gonna win because--
- You already got that app.
- Yeah the main barrier is like
I gotta download something,
man, I don't have good service here.
- But you get so excited--
- Now I gotta take pictures
of my license, I don't
travel with my license.
- I've never been so
willing to download an app
as when I was about to get on
a scooter, I will say that.
Like when I'm about to get on a scooter,
I'll download any app.
I mean it could be like a
credit card number sharing app,
like HackMe.com app,
I would download that.
That's how excited I was,
dead set on gettin' on that scooter.
- That's an interesting app.
- I would agree to anything.
I mean I basically signed my life away.
Yeah, I'm wearing a
helmet, wink, wink, wink.
You know?
- Yeah I'm hard headed.
(Link chuckles)
- And then people are taking
them home and chargin' them up
and makin' a little
extra scratch, you know?
- Yeah.
- It's good for everybody.
And they're not gas powered.
Technically it's good for the--
- Maybe it's not too late.
- The environment.
- Maybe we could get in on this.
Mythical Scooters, you know what,
we make ours three-wheeled.
(clicks tongue) Safer.
- Safer.
- It's shaped like a pyramid.
It's double-wheeled in the back.
- No two wheels in the front
like when a kid's learning
how to ride a scooter.
Yeah.
- Like a spider?
- Yeah and we market it to children.
That's what we do.
We're gonna do that but first,
we're just gonna promote what
we got which is this hat.
It's a GMM hat.
It's got some camouflage to
it, it's got some orange to it,
it's got accoutrements.
- We also got mugs, the Ear Biscuits mug.
It's beige.
- It's so good to drink out of.
It's hefty.
Once you get this thing
you'll be like man,
this is a high quality mug.
- Oh, Feldman wants me
to say that it's cream.
I go with beige.
I think beige is one of the
most pleasing colors of nature.
It is the color of most things.
When the world ends,
when the universe finally just
dissipates into nothingness,
it will be dissipating into beige.
- Beige is the entropy of color.
- Beige is before all
things and after all things.
Beige.
- I would venture to guess
before and after all the things
would be just blackness.
- No, it's beigeness.
That's a common misconception.
- Well I'm glad you set it straight
because you had that knowledge.
- Beigeness, in the beginning--
- You know where to go--
- Was beigeness.
- Mythical.store.
Rep your boys, drink, drink
from the cup of biscuit.
- Okay so a couple of interesting
things about this tour.
Now as we have, as
we've stated repeatedly,
but it cannot be overstated apparently
because even some of
the VIPs who showed up
to meet and greet us
after a few of the shows,
multiple people would say
something along these lines,
"Man, I didn't know you guys played music.
"I mean I thought this
was gonna be two hours
"of Will It Burrito."
- Somebody said that specifically, yeah.
- Uh and listen--
- That would be a big burrito.
- Now I do under--
- We could do it
and we would do it and we might do it.
- Yeah you think that's a
great idea but that's like--
- We didn't just do it.
- Not this year.
I think that it's a little,
we have a little bit of a
branding problem, right,
because the thing that
we're known for the most
is Good Mythical Morning
and let's be honest,
if you were to watch just
a little highlight reel
of what we do on the
show, you might not come
to the conclusion that these
idiots had any other talents
other than not being able to eat things.
- Yeah I think someone said,
"I didn't know you guys
were talented." (chuckles)
We got, and these are like
fans paying to meet us.
I mean these are like
true Mythical Beasts.
I didn't know, but
things come out sideways
when you're meeting
somebody that you've watched
a lot on the internet so
I just find humor in it
but I know they didn't mean
anything by it and I'm like--
- Well and on top of that,
another thing I'll say is that,
let's say that you're a fan of GMM
and you've been watching that
and then what you have seen
of our other work is say, our
really popular rap battles
or other music videos
that we made on YouTube.
Again, anybody can make a music video.
Anybody can sing along with a track.
Anybody can have their voice Auto-Tuned
so I think a lot of people are just like,
oh well of course,
you've done music videos
but to sit down for
almost two hours for us
to do live instrument-based
music is something
that a lot of people just
aren't expecting, but again,
as we explained at every show,
one of the things that's
really cool about it
is that it's sort of a
returning to the roots
of what we did before,
before YouTube started,
our comedy was primarily just funny songs
that we performed live for
people and then we turned some
of those into music
videos and that was sort
of the beginning of our comedy career.
So this is kinda going
back to what started it all
and anyway--
- It's really fun to do.
I'm very glad that this
is what we decided to do
when we now tour and by
the way we are continuing
to tour so if you wanna come
see us, RhettAndLinkLive.com.
Can I plug the dates, I should--
- Plug the dates man, plug it.
- [Link] Las Vegas on June
21st, Salt Lake City 22nd,
Denver the 23rd, Milwaukee the
25th, Indianapolis the 26th,
Detroit the 27th, Omaha the
29th, Minneapolis, the 30th.
RhettAndLinkLive.com, get your tickets.
I just had such a good
time because I really enjoy
singing the songs that
we've written over the years
but it also does capture a lot and I think
of what people like about
GMM and that's the fact
that we can kinda, it's not scripted.
We're just kind of in between songs,
we're just kinda cuttin'
up and seeing what happens.
- Right.
- And on any given night,
you never know what's gonna happen.
At the beginning, the songs were,
we were a little more
rusty, by the time we got
to Nashville, we kinda had the songs down
and we weren't gonna forget
lyrics and stuff like that,
but on the first night,
one of the new songs
when you moved over to the piano,
like you started playing it then
you never started singing it and I'm like,
he doesn't remember the lyrics and all
of a sudden you're like, I
can't remember the words,
and that was the most fun part
of the night because like--
- Oh for you. (chuckles)
Real fun for you.
- When something goes
wrong, it's like okay,
everybody in the whole place
knows this was not planned
so now what are we gonna do?
And so that's what's fun is
when you don't have to wig out,
you can just say, you can
just have fun with it,
and that was fun.
I had fun messing with
you and I knew the lyrics
so I chose not to tell you and
kinda make you squirm but--
- I sat there and played the piano
for what felt like five minutes.
- (laughs) It was funny, man.
- Played the intro.
- People loved it.
- Oh I know people loved
it I'm just saying that--
- 'Cause it's honest.
- I was like I really
don't know how to access what the first,
the first words to the song are.
But like you said, by the
time we got to Nashville,
we had the songs figured out.
I think the thing is is that I don't mind
and actually I look forward
to what's gonna happen
in between the songs and what
stories are we gonna tell
and it's very loose and
where is it gonna go,
what kinda bent are we gonna
come up with in the moment,
but I don't want all
the bits to come from--
- Fails.
- Screwing the songs up.
- Well, they didn't.
- And they didn't,
they didn't, 'cause again,
I have a lot more fun,
the more I know the song--
- It frees you up to then--
- Then I can actually have fun
in the midst of it because it's like,
it's just one of those, it's
a little bit of a blessing
and a curse that we get
to do so many things
but because we do so many things,
it isn't like we sit
around and like rehearse--
- Right.
- Our music all the time.
- We don't rehearse
enough but then we, again,
we turn the mess ups into
okay, we can make fun
of that happening and we can
kinda milk it for comedy but--
- And maybe we'll--
- It's also a very safe space.
- Maybe we'll have, I mean
my goal is for us to have
at least another new song
that no one has heard at all
by the time we--
- Yeah in June, in June.
- Go out on the summer tour.
- But it's also great, I'm very grateful
that it's such a safe
space for us to perform
because everybody is, even
if they didn't know what
to expect, they're a
dedicated Mythical Beast
or they're there with someone
who's already oriented
to what's going on so
it's not like we have
to win the crowd over.
We just have to give 'em,
we just have to have fun
and I think it was a lot
of fun and I can't imagine
how if you're, if touring
is your first thing
and you're trying to win
over a crowd and trying
to build an audience that
way, that would be difficult,
so it's nice that we don't--
- Oh yeah.
- We don't have to do that.
- Well you know, speaking
of winning over a crowd
who's not familiar with
you, one of the things
that made this tour unique
was Britton opening up for us.
- Yeah.
- And of course, we talk
about Britton a lot,
Britton Buchanon, Link's
cousin who was on The Voice
and is living with Link and Christy now.
And we honestly didn't
know how that was gonna go
because his songs are
not, it's not comedy.
- Right.
- He's just like a
a legitimately great songwriter
and musician and singer
and so we were like well, we enjoy this.
We think you'll enjoy it too and you know
that there's the family connection
but we would kinda go out
and watch, not go out into the crowd
but kinda go side stage
and watch Britton perform
and it's like thank you
to all the Mythical Beasts
who received him so warmly but I'll say
that you weren't doing
it out of any sort of--
- Obligation.
- Obligation or pity,
I think everyone was legitimate,
everything that I've seen on the internet,
everybody was legitimately
impressed because he's good.
- Yeah, and he did a good
job winning people over
with the stuff that he would
say in between songs too so.
- Yeah we won't spoil any surprises.
I think we're gonna talk
a little bit more about
what Britton does on tour on LTAT
so we won't get into that too much here
but we also traveled with him.
So he was with us the entire time.
- Speaking of traveling, so we were,
we have the tour bus situation
and then on the tour bus,
you got the front part
and then you go back
to the middle part and there's
these, I call 'em coffins.
You sleep in a coffin,
they're like two high,
on some buses they're three high.
- Well these were two high--
- And you're sleeping
on this thing.
- I mean you can imagine,
the first time we did this,
there were three high so--
- You can't sit up in it.
- And I can't even, I
can't lay all the way down.
They don't make them six foot seven.
These things are probably--
- Six two,
six three.
- Uh--
- I could stretch out.
- I think they might--
- At six foot--
- I think they might be
just below my height, I
think it might be like six
and a half feet plus the siding
or whatever so six five so--
- How do you sleep in there?
- Well not well.
- Because you couldn't--
- To begin with I'll say.
For a couple reasons, I mean
not being able to stretch out,
I sleep on my side so
I'm not at full height.
I sleep like a baby in the womb and--
- Like with your knees under your chin?
- I mean if I can get 'em there, yeah.
Completely balled up
ready for tornadoes and--
- Like in a tuck position.
- I sleep on my side so
I'm a little bit curled up
but in my bed if I'm sleeping on my side,
there's moments during the
night where I'll kinda wake up
and I'll just for a moment just sort
of stretch out completely being like--
- Just unfurl the flag so to speak.
- Just to remember my height.
- Length.
- You know and then turn to the other side
so you can't do that and
also I'm such a light sleeper
that pothole, I wake up.
Fast turn, I wake up.
- Oh yeah?
- That's not fun.
But I did get better.
I did get better on the second night.
- I like sleepin' in a confined space.
I don't know something
about it I just felt like
a cozy little child.
- If it was a little bit
longer and we weren't moving--
- In a coffin.
- It would be great.
Once we arrived--
- That's a morbid thought.
- To the destination and
then they kinda let you
wake up on your own whenever
you happen to wake up,
I'll sleep indefinitely in that scenario.
- Well but you didn't.
I mean that first morning there, I woke up
and I realized, I was starting
to realize we're not moving.
And your coffin has a curtain
so it's like pretty dark
in there even if it was bright outside
which it turns out it was
'cause I looked out my curtain
and then I got a text from
Jenna and she was like,
instructions are on the
counter when you wanna come
into the hotel where, and I
assume where everybody else
already was because I didn't hear anything
and then so I got out,
no one was on the bus
and then I look at
Britton's curtain's closed
and I don't open the curtain
'cause I didn't know what
position or state he might be in
in therms of clothing so
I just poked the curtain
and I did hit something so
I'm like oh he is in there
and I was like time to get up.
It was 11:30.
(chuckles)
Britton and I were the
only two people on the bus
and we oriented ourselves
and we go to exit the bus
and Britton goes down the steps
and he turns the doorknob.
It doesn't respond and then
he's like shaking all the,
he's really pulling on
the lever and I'm like,
"Well hold on don't break the door."
And he's like, "We're locked in, man."
I'm like "Well no we're
not, just, you know,"
and you look at the front of this bus
which we don't know anything
about and there's buttons,
it's like the cockpit of a airplane.
There's buttons everywhere.
And so we start pushin' all of 'em.
(chuckles) And we push
the ones that look like
they have something to do with a door.
- Right.
- And I heard something
click around the door
but it still wouldn't open,
and then I'm over there
puttin' all my weight onto it.
We were locked on the bus.
For a day.
(Rhett chuckles)
The whole day.
No we eventually got off
but that was our first bus experience.
I like sleepin' on the bus but
I don't like being confined
and not being able to exit the bus,
that's a little disconcerting.
- Well that raises an
interesting question.
Are there other exists?
Is there an exit in the back?
Because there should be
exits because what if
there was a fire--
- You thinkin' about this now?
- What if there's a fire on the bus?
There should be multiple exits
on the bus--
- I guess we need
an orientation.
- Obviously there's a exit
in the back of a school bus
but it's a room in the back of this thing.
- There's exits on the
roof of a school bus
and every window is an exit.
Like if a school bus lays
on its side or something,
you can go out the top of a school bus.
- Right.
- Yeah or the window.
- You can get out of a school
bus in lots of different ways.
- Every which way.
- You don't need a button.
- Need no button.
- Maybe we should be
traveling in a school bus,
I'm just sayin'.
- Well you do have me
thinkin' that now I need
to start checkin' for exits.
- I'm a little worried.
- That's why Christy
should have come with me.
I know that's the first thing
she looks for is the exit
out of everything.
I mean not our relationship.
We're doing great.
- Hmm, interesting.
- We played at Columbus
that night once I got out
of the bus and got off the scooter.
That was fun, that was a great show.
I mean in general I'll just shout out,
thanks to all the crowds
everywhere, super supportive
and then when we do the
meet and greet afterward,
it's always special because
you kinda get to hear
just a little bit from fans in terms of
how they watch the show, what
watching us means to them
and it always blows me away how
the nature of our show being daily
and I guess our friendship
and I mean there's a lot
of intangibles that being on the inside,
it's just hard to get perspective
on how people enjoy the show
or what it means to them
and helps them get through hard times
and they can count on
it and stuff like that
so it's really helpful to get out there
and meet the people, you know?
To press the flesh.
It really puts things in perspective.
- I mean everything except that last part.
I understand, I mean yes.
- Press the flesh is not the right word.
That was a political term
that you can't use anymore.
- That was for handshakes and we do,
if you want a hug, we hug.
We let you initiate whatever you wanna do.
But yeah I think that--
- So flesh is pressed but I
mean it's upon their initiation.
- Yeah I just don't like
to use flesh and press
in the context of the
meet and greet, I just--
- That's true.
- I'd just kinda like to
abandon that terminology.
- Yeah let's abandon it.
Let's lock it in the bus.
- But I did see some
people on Twitter talking
before this run and they were saying,
"I just, I don't know.
"I don't know, I'm nervous.
"I don't know what to say and,"
and I think people have
a tendency to feel like
they have to have some
sort of something prepared
or as if they're auditioning to be
the perfect Mythical Beast in that moment
and that's not what it's about at all.
Whatever you wanna do,
I mean we have one girl who sang for us.
- Got another guy who
performed a rap for us.
- You know and those are awesome.
- It's hilarious.
- If you wanna do that,
do that.
- I mean it was supposed
to be funny and it was.
- We don't encourage everyone to do that
because I mean we'd be
there for seven hours
if everyone had a performance.
- We'd like for everyone
to perform some sort of,
bring your talent.
- But ultimately what,
and some people are like,
you know what, I just, I
wanna hand you this note
because this is everything
that I want to say
and it's more than I have
time to say in this time
and some people are just like
hey I just want a picture.
Whatever you want it to be,
just know that we're not,
the way that we approach
this is we are 100% grateful.
We are in a attitude of
gratitude, a stance of,
mm--
- Prance.
- Something that rhymes with sta,
we're basically just
humbled that you guys come
to the show, some of you
want to spend a little time
with us and get a picture
and we're just happy that you're there.
You don't have to say or do anything.
You're not fitting any
particular expectation so
if that makes you feel
less nervous about it
then go with that because
we're not thinking about it
in that way, in fact, I heard,
there was one girl at one of the shows
who actually backed out
of the line before she got
to the end and I think we're gonna end up
sending her something and
send her all the stuff
that she would have gotten in
the meet and greet line but--
- It's kinda nerve-wracking--
- And I understand that.
Some people deal with anxiety--
- It is nerve-wracking, man.
- More than others, I get it.
- It's nerve-wracking to stand
in a line to meet somebody.
- Oh I totally get that.
- Because you can see the
line just kinda move along
and then all of a sudden
you're like the next person.
I remember a few years back
when DanTDM came to Long Beach
and Lincoln was a fan of his
and I was like I can get you
in to see him, man, I got connections.
And so we went in the meet and greet line
and we're in the line and I
realized that I was nervous.
I was like why am I nervous?
Just by virtue of being in a
line with a bunch of people
who are also nervous,
it's like contagious.
- Yeah.
- And you build this
expectation, it's like,
there is this moment of
okay, we're gonna shake hands
and I'm supposed to say something.
I have to say something,
if I don't say anything,
that could be weird, you know?
- Yeah but even the people
who don't say anything,
it's not weird for us.
- Everything like that
does make me anxious.
- So I mean yeah and I'm not
saying at all don't be nervous,
I'm just saying, just be
yourself, if yourself is nervous,
then be nervous, if yourself is excited,
then just be excited and there's
no judgment at all from us.
And I know, listen, we're
bigger than you realize.
- Physically.
- I am,
I know that I am intimidating physically.
People are sometimes afraid to look at me
because I think I'm
just like, I look like--
- It's odd.
- I look like Detlef Schrempf or whatever
that NBA basketball player
was, you know what I'm saying?
I'm a huge person.
I have a lot of hair on my
face, I look like a hawk.
- You're weird lookin', man.
- I've been called a falcon
by a drunk man in a van one time.
- You look like a falcon.
- Man.
- You look like a tall Detlef
Schrempf-lookin' falcon.
- But I'm very soft and inviting.
I have sweaty hands, you
can shake them if you want.
- That didn't make it any less weird.
(Rhett laughs)
We should talk about hot chicken.
So we get to Nashville and
we had a little more time
in Nashville 'cause we had a one day break
and man, by the time I got in line at,
we decided to go to Hattie B's even though
Mythical Chef Josh told
us to get hot chicken
from Bolton's Spicy Chicken and Fish.
And even though Wikipedia
says that Prince's
is the originator of hot chicken.
- We didn't go there.
- We were kinda starving, delirious
and closest to Hattie B's.
- And also we tend to be
very dependent upon Yelp.
- And there's so many Yelp reviews.
- A lot of people--
- Love it.
- Don't like that, I mean
don't like when you're
that dependent on Yelp
but I just, you know,
4,000 reviews, four and a half stars,
you know it's gonna be good.
- And we get there, we scootered there.
- Of course we did, nearly died.
- We're there for a couple
of minutes and then we hear,
well it's 45 minutes from
where you are in line.
- Yeah it was like
being on Space Mountain.
- I showed up starving, I was like,
I don't wait this long, I just don't.
It doesn't add up, I started
looking for Bolton's.
Like we could travel to
Bolton's via scooter,
eat and be done and still come back
and not have gone through
this line probably.
- Yeah but that to me, that's
all part of the experience
of going to a place like
that and I will say,
I do think it's worth
noting that hot chicken
has been exported from Nashville
and of course it's in
LA and there's a number
of places that serve it,
Howlin' Rays probably
being the most popular
and I have seen the Howlin'
Rays line before but neither
of us and I don't know if
we were just holdin' out
for Nashville or just
happened circumstantially--
- And never been there.
- We had never had hot chicken.
- Well you know, we did our
Instagram stories from the line
and then we finally get
up there and we order
and it's, I, you know
what, I'll agree with you.
I actually ended up
saying, I'll say it again,
I'm glad that I waited 45 minutes
and I kinda learned my lesson.
You talk about gettin' nervous in a line.
I mean in this type of
line when the only thing
you gotta do is pay and eat food, boy,
that's a great scenario.
It's a great payoff and you're
talking like Magic Mountain
or Space Mountain--
- Are you saying
we should serve hot chicken
at the meet and greet?
- I'm saying in contrast--
- Logistically,
that would be difficult--
- To that, you don't have
to say anything besides
order what you want
at the end and then--
- You gotta pick your spice level though.
- But my point is the wait
made it taste that much better.
- Oh yeah, delayed gratification, man.
It's the spice of life, it's
the hot chicken of life.
- And so I don't like spicy
foods, I've been burned,
pun intended, from the show
so now anything that's spicy
to me is like, it's triggering physically
so I start to feel a little nauseous,
but I didn't wanna just
try mild or medium,
I'm like, if it's called hot chicken
I should order a hot.
- You gotta get hot.
And for those of you who
aren't familiar with it,
'cause I had an idea,
I thought that hot
chicken was fried chicken
with hot sauce on it.
- Like basted on it,
kinda like a hot wing.
- But it is not that.
It is chicken that has spice
actually in the breading,
first of all, so that's the
first thing that happens
and so if you were to peel back the skin,
you would see a little red layer of spice
that is part of, so it gets
all the way onto the chicken,
and then on top of that,
depending on what spice level you get,
they add a dry rub.
Now I'm sure there's some
places that do a sauce
but these places do a dry rub on top of,
so it's basically like a powdery thing.
I think there might be some
sauce as well on Hattie B's.
I couldn't really tell--
- It's a little,
there's a dryness and a wetness to it
but there's definitely a redness to it
that makes it a bit intimidating.
But I was so hungry.
- But the levels were
southern, which means no spice and yes,
someone in our group
who will remain nameless
but he's one of Britton's
friends, that's what he got.
- No one who works for us.
- He's also a Carolina
fan so it all adds up.
The next level is mild and
then medium and then hot
and then damn hot and
then shut the cluck up.
Those are the levels
and we all went with hot.
- Hot.
- So Jenna got hot, we
got hot, Britton got hot.
- And let me tell you, it was hot.
But let me tell you something else.
It tasted great.
- Flavor, man.
- Like the hotness tasted great.
- So much flavor.
- And it was big and juicy,
oh it was so good, I mean it was--
- And you got the dark--
- I love a good
food experience, man, you know.
And I think it's turned
me back onto hotness.
When I'm ridin' back home comin' back,
we landed in LA.
It's an hour drive to
get back to the studio
to get in our cars.
I found myself on Yelp lookin'
for the hot chicken places around here.
- And there's quite a few.
- I'm like man,
I'm back on the spicy train.
- We might have to have
a hot chicken taste test
Instagram story like when we went around
and tried to find the best taco,
we might have to do that with hot chicken.
- But I did not order the
upper echelons of hotness
like you did.
- So you can get a tender
or a wing by itself for
$2 extra and add that
to your order so a lot of people do this
just as a novelty kinda thing
so I had a show, you know,
and also I feel like I've eaten
the world's hottest pepper,
twice, so I was like, you know what,
I'm just gonna do a damn hot tender.
And then Britton, you know, he's 19.
His body can take anything at this point.
He got a shut the cluck up wing.
No, a tender, he got a
shut the cluck up tender.
And if you were following
along on our Instagram stories,
@rhettmc and @linklamont--
- Oh thank you.
- You would have seen all this happen.
- And Britton's I guess,
you can shout his out.
- @brittonbuchanon, follow
him on Instagram too
because the action's happenin' over there
when we're traveling.
- It was funny 'cause (chuckles),
he ate that thing, he thought
he was gonna be all right,
and then his face just started crying.
His eyeballs just sweated.
- Right.
He cried quite a bit.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The damn hot tender was
damn hot but it was like
as I was eating it, I was like,
I could have gotten the sandwich this way
and I would have been okay.
- He texted us and said
that his dad looked into it
'cause he tried to talk
his dad into eating one.
He said that it had--
- The top shut the cluck up.
- Yeah it had scorpion
pepper and ghost pepper
in the--
- And habanero,
equal parts of all three.
- Gosh.
- And it's like a powder
which is incidentally,
it's like the heat is super intense
but it dissipates more quickly
because it doesn't have an
oil base to it the way that,
it doesn't have an oil carrier
the way that sauce does,
'cause sauce will get into
your skin because literally,
when you get essential
oils and you put them
into like a olive oil
carrier so they'll like--
- Yeah.
- Be carried further
and they go into your skin.
That's why eating the pepper straight
because you've got that
oil and then even worse,
when you eat a sauce.
- Mm-mm.
- It sticks with you, you feel it later,
you feel it in your stomach,
you feel it on the way out
and it's still incredibly
hot in each stage.
Something about the dry rub makes this,
it's like a flash, bang, of hotness
but for me, an hour later I'd forgotten
that I ate something so hot.
- Well even when you're eating it,
I highly recommend eating it
with a slaw which was great
and a pickle.
- You need something creamy.
- The pickle and the
bread that comes with--
- You got every creamy side.
- Oh yeah.
- You got the mac and cheese,
the potato salad--
- Potato salad.
- And the slaw.
- I did.
- And I ended up getting collard
greens and beans of course,
the beans are good.
- That doesn't help with the heat though.
- But they actually, the
collard greens had this
enhancing effect 'cause of the vinegar,
it enhanced the heat.
- That's tough.
- So anyway Hattie B's was
excellent but of course,
because we didn't wanna
come back and face Josh,
and also Josh made an
incredible dinner recommendation
for a place called Husk
that we went that was--
- Gosh, that was amazing.
- One of the best meals
we've ever had.
- Shout out to all you people
working at Husk.
The people in the
kitchen knew who we were.
And started sending out
stuff that we didn't order.
They stuffed us like pigs.
- Oh gosh.
- They stuffed us with pigs.
- Yeah.
- It was crazy.
- And every--
- It was amazing!
- First of all,
the waitress described the items
and I feel like she spoke
for like 12 minutes unbroken
describing the different items,
then she would say things
like, well first we take this
and we put it under ashes for 12 hours
and then we take it and we
rub it across a pig's back
until it squeals and then
we capture the squeal
and we put it in a bottle
and we sprinkle it on top
of the collards and then
we take the collards
and we run them into the past.
And then we bring them out of the past
once they have the essence of the old days
and then we bring them to the table
and then we grind them
up and sprinkle them
on the other foods that
you will be enjoying.
I mean I had a frickin'
whiskey with ham in it.
(Link chuckles)
- Yeah that was crazy, man.
- It was so good.
- What a night.
- And it's in an old house.
It's in an old house that
apparently is haunted,
so Husk, go to Husk.
- It was a surgeon from
like the Civil War.
- Civil War, yeah, but so
Josh told us to go to there
so we felt like we had to
follow his recommendation.
- But we also felt like
we couldn't come back
until we went to Bolton's
Hot Chicken and Fish.
- [Rhett] Right.
- Hot, yeah, Spicy Chicken and Fish,
that's what it's called.
They got a cockatrice breathing fire,
well they got a chicken
breathing fire out front.
- Again, Instagram, we showed you this.
- They've got a sign when
you order there and it says,
basically proceed at your own risk.
Do not touch your eyes or babies.
When eating our hot chicken and fish.
And--
- Do not touch babies.
- And someone had said--
- Think about that.
- How bad would you feel
if you sauce a baby.
Oh man I'm sorry, I just sauced your baby.
- Well it's really dry rubbing a baby.
- I'm so sorry, I didn't
mean to dry rub your baby.
(Rhett chuckles)
If you've got a nasty habit
of dry rubbin' a baby in the eyes,
do not go to Nashville.
- Yeah, right.
- You're not even invited.
- Mm-mm.
- You cannot, first of all,
that's a habit you need to break.
What are you doing touching babies' eyes?
- Yeah.
- If a baby's got an
eye booger, who cares?
Just let him have it.
It's actually probably a good thing,
it's like a protective layer
at the corner of the eyes.
- Yeah.
- You don't need to--
- I think in general I think you shouldn't
touch the face of a baby.
- Don't touch babies' faces.
- You know.
- Eyes, like oh look at,
that baby's so cute.
Can I rub its eyes, what?
- Mm-hmm.
- And to have to put up a sign,
I mean what does that say
about the people of Nashville?
A lot of baby eye touchers--
- They been dry rubbin' babies.
- Eye touchers.
- They were dry rubbin'
babies left and right
before they put that sign up.
- It's probably good for the baby though.
- The spice levels at Bolton,
it's a different scale.
- We were told this.
- There's no spice and then there's light
or something like that, then there's mild,
then there's medium, then there's hot.
- But they said whatever
you got at Hattie B's
is what we were told by
two different people,
go one level lower--
- Level down.
- I'm grateful that we did.
- So yeah and they were right, so--
- It was a different experience.
- Hot there was medium at Bolton's.
And they don't have a sandwich there.
It's just the fried
chicken, similar sides.
I tried the beans, actually, well,
I'll just go ahead and
say that not just Josh,
but most Nashvillians that we ran into
and said we had been to Hattie B's,
they had this disappointed
look on their face,
they were like yeah of course
you guys did the touristy thing.
You should really go to Bolton's,
you should go to Prince's.
- Mm-hmm.
- Guys.
- And we did, well we went to one.
It's not--
- It's good.
- Bolton's was really good.
- Really good.
Really good and the
atmosphere was so authentic.
- It's like cinder block
buildings that look like,
they look like bunkers almost.
Look like I was eatin'
at a barbecue bunker.
- Right.
- Really, really rustic.
- But we gotta say.
- We both enjoyed Hattie B's
more, I mean it was just--
- Yeah.
- It was more
of a distinct thing.
- Now they do have hot fish.
You can get all the same
spices on fish at Bolton's
and so we got a hot fish and
we went all the way to hot
and they got whitefish, they
got catfish, they got grouper.
We got the whitefish
'cause it was at the top
of the menu, we figured that
was the one that was suggested.
- I would recommend doing both though.
- Yeah yeah you should try
that 'cause I never had
a spicy fish like that, it was very good.
- We should skip to the Ryman
because we're at this
point in our conversation
and we haven't gotten
to it but being a fan
of old country music and we went through
the Country Music Hall of
Fame and took our time,
had a great time, they
had an outlaws exhibit
which was amazing but
in a lot of the pictures
that you'll see throughout the
Country Music Hall of Fame,
you'll see people performing
at the Ryman Auditorium
because it was the home
of the Grand Ole Opry
for 30 years.
- And lots of people--
- Which was the distinct,
it was the place where country
music legends were made
and certified.
- Yeah so basically anybody
who's anybody in country
music like old country--
- Yeah.
- Has played,
and then of course--
- Hank Williams.
- All the new acts have
played there as well because--
- Elvis Presley.
- It's still got--
- Played there.
- This incredible history.
- But the Ryman Auditorium
was originally built
as an actual church like
a revival venue and--
- And you can totally
tell when you go in there
because it's all pews,
it's all a big circle.
It's a huge balcony that follows
the same semi-circular
pattern and then you've got
the stained glass windows,
I mean super famous.
It's super famous for the history
but it's also super
famous for the acoustics
because it's all wood.
- Yeah.
- And the circular thing is just like one
of the best sounding places
that you can play music.
- And I'm doing some
research when we're in D.C.
I wanna see Merle playing here and I mean
he first played there as
he was starting his career
in 1967 but then Johnny
Cash who was a member
of the Grand Ole Opry
and was then kicked out
and you can see that in
the movie Walk the Line,
he was let go but then he came back
when he had his own television
show The Johnny Cash show.
He insisted that it be filmed
at the Ryman Auditorium,
at the home of the Grand Ole Opry.
So they would film his
show there and I mean,
Johnny Cash is bringin'
Bob Dylan on his show.
I mean this is an amazing
institution within an institution,
just his show, and he had as
Merle was gaining popularity,
he comes on the show and
seeing the two of them interact
is like, it just gives
me goosebumps thinking
about that footage but one
story in particular is amazing,
that of course, Merle was in prison.
And just like the lyric in Mama Tried,
he did turn 21 in prison.
He wasn't serving life
without parole but--
- 15 years of something like that.
- And Johnny Cash knew this
but he encouraged Merle
to talk about it openly,
his time in prison,
which he hadn't done, now some people knew
that he had been in prison but it was
on The Johnny Cash Show, on
the stage that we performed on
that Merle and a
conversation with Johnny Cash
told the world for the
first time that he was...
He was a prisoner, he was an ex-con.
- Mm-hmm.
- And not only that,
he told it in the context of the story of
when Johnny Cash on
many occasions would go
and perform concerts at prisons,
Folsom Prison concert is a famous album
but so is his San Quentin performance.
But he performed at San
Quentin a number of times
and one of those times, Merle
Haggard was in the audience.
- [Rhett] Mm-hmm.
- As a frickin' inmate and
he's like telling that story
so it's basically his coming
out that hey I was an ex-con
and blowing people's minds that Johnny,
I was at your concert as an inmate and so,
and to know that happened on that stage
just kinda blew my mind
and then I realized, man,
I'm gettin' nervous.
- Well I was already nervous.
(chuckles)
Before we went to
the hall of fame, because first of all,
everyone who we talked to,
if we say we're playing the Ryman,
like you're playing the Ry--
- Yeah.
- You're going to this sacred place
and I'm also thinking
about the thing that it is
that we do which is, we're
not country musicians,
I mean, we're gonna be actin'
like fools up in this place,
you know, we're playing
music but it's stupid
in a lot of ways.
- We got a lot of testicle jokes.
- Yeah, and so--
- And we've got a whole
rap set which feels weird.
- Which feels a little
out of place in the Ryman but
so in seeing all that footage
and people who made their debut there
because one of the cool things about
the Country Music Hall of Fame in addition
to the memorabilia, the
archival sorta stuff,
or the artifacts is all the
video that they have in there.
- Right.
- They've got so,
all these, like you said the
footage of the conversation
on The Johnny Cash Show with Merle,
but so much of that and
so many pictures I'm like,
that's the Ryman, that's
the Ryman, that's the Ryman,
and then I kept saying like
we're playing there tonight
and I started thinking a couple things
like A, I'm way more
nervous than I usually am
before a show.
And two, we had decided
to play two Merle songs.
Two of our favorite Merle songs.
- Which is something we've never done.
We don't cover anybody's songs
and we've never performed
Merle's songs publicly
that I can remember.
- Right and so we did one
that is a really popular
old school Merle song and
then one that's a little bit
of a deeper cut and I was thinking
I might cry.
- Oh.
- I was like I don't want, you know,
I don't wanna cry during this thing.
Because I can't cry and
still continue to sing.
I'm not one of those people
who can like, you know--
- Cry-sing?
- Cry-sing.
Some people can.
- Kinda like Vince Gill.
He seems like he's always cry-singing.
- My voice would break and so I was like
I don't want that to happen so you know,
I don't know how I'm gonna
take my mind off that.
But a few things about the
show, I mean first of all,
thankfully we did have everything down
from a musical standpoint
by the time we got there.
It did sound like we could
hear ourselves really well
and you sorta feel the power of the music
kinda going out and
coming around that circle
and coming back to you.
And also, you can hear every single thing
that is being, the crowd
reaction is so immediate
'cause they're right there
on you and it's 2200 people,
it's a small, small venue
and they're kinda on top
of you in a lot of ways 'cause
you got that huge balcony,
so the furthest person from
you is still relatively close.
- And it makes such a big difference.
I mean in the little bit
of touring that we've done,
it's like, every venue is different
and you never know exactly
what you're gonna get
and what crowd is gonna show up.
But everything lined up, I mean,
the crowd was so
boisterous and responsive.
- Oh yeah.
- You know I had somebody,
I don't know how we got
to this me asking for anti-bacterial soap
and then somebody's like throwing--
- Hand sanitizer.
- Hand sanitizer up
at me and like, I
emptied the entire bottle
that she threw to me into my hand
and then I didn't know what to do with it
and we came up with something.
It was a lot of fun, man,
everybody was just lovin',
everybody was having a good time.
So by the time in the middle of the set
when we performed Silver Wings,
you felt like you weren't gonna cry?
'Cause people, like, people
said that they cried.
And I was like yes.
- It was very, very emotional
for me, like playing both
that and then Driftwood,
and we played Driftwood with Britton,
he got up there and killed
the solo, the guitar solo
and it was emotional for sure
but I didn't think that
I was gonna break down
at that moment.
So the show just went on, it was great,
and we got to that last song that we sing
which is a little bit of
an emotional, it's funny,
but it's got an emotional
quality and tone to it.
The song that we close the show out with,
and you knew this.
Most people probably
didn't pick up on the fact
that I flubbed two lyrics.
We ended up just changing
in the moment one lyric
that was from a different part of the song
and there was one part
where I didn't come in
but you sang that part,
whatever, which by this point
in the tour wasn't typical.
- Right.
- Especially that song.
And I told you later,
I was like--
- What was happening?
- I was so in the moment
and thinking that I cannot
believe how much fun this is.
I cannot believe how good this is.
You know what I'm sayin', not good like,
I can't believe how good we are,
just how good this is all lining up.
- Yeah you were savoring it,
man, I think that's great.
Yeah.
- I lost the ability
to be in the song 'cause
I was so in the moment.
It's like I kinda left
my body for a second
and took a little flight
around the Ryman and communed
with the spirits of old country.
And then came back in
in my body and was like,
oh, I should be singing.
(chuckles)
- Yeah, it was magical, man, I mean,
was it the peak of our career?
Yeah, I mean--
- It hasn't gotten any better
than that for me personally.
- Well it was two days ago.
- No I'm saying, people are
like, what's the best moment
in your career--
- Oh wow.
- I cannot think of any time
where I felt as fulfilled
in what we get to do.
- Right.
- As in that moment.
- Because the other things,
I mean you put out the internet
video and it's just like
you can only be so
fulfilled by the response
of the comments, I mean, if you make,
if you craft a documentary or a series
or anything and you
screen it and then people,
you're watching people
from the back of the room
and then they're clapping, it's
like that is very thrilling.
But it's not the same as performing.
I mean, as having that moment
of all the faces are staring
back at you and you're like,
I'm savoring this like the first bite
of hot chicken I ever had.
You never have, I mean, you
could read about hot chicken,
you can make analogies about hot chicken
at the end of podcasts.
- Right.
- But until you eat the
hot chicken on the stage
of the Ryman.
- Mm-hmm.
- Oh shoot, that would have been peak.
That's, we blew it.
- That would have been too much.
That would have been sensory overload.
- That's gonna be our next tour.
I mean that's what
people want anyway right?
- The hot chicken tour?
- Yeah we're just gonna get
on stage and eat hot chicken.
- (sighs) Well and that's another thing,
I'm glad you brought that up.
Not the hot chicken but the eating thing
because you know me and we've
talked about this before,
it's like, another reason
that it's so fulfilling to me,
it's like okay it's cool
when we, it's like oh,
we got to, oh there's 15
million people subscribed
to Good Mythical Morning
and that's awesome.
And it's, you know what,
it's why people show up
at our frickin' show, let's be honest.
It's why people can show
up and watch us sing.
They're not showing up to
watch us sing primarily,
most people because they've seen us sing,
they've seen us do weird
stuff on the internet
and they wanna come hang out with us.
But because I truly believe
that we crafted something.
We have crafted a show that I
feel good about artistically
and creatively and again
that's the kinda thing
that kinda gets me going, right?
Obviously I love the
stuff that's not planned
and the humor that happens in the moment
and the things that make
that particular show unique,
but the thing that really
gets me going is like
sitting down and over the
course of a labored process,
creating something special
that then is crafted
with the real time reception
of an audience in mind.
You know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
And it's very rewarding
when it comes together.
- And then being able to go out there
and actually execute it
and see the real time,
feel the real time
reaction from an audience
in a place that's so special,
the combination of those things
and the way that it came
together, I was just like,
it doesn't get any better than
this, I mean like we could,
hopefully we'll continue
to do great things.
Hopefully we've got bigger
and better things ahead of us
and there's other creative
things that we want to do.
But regardless of how well those things go
and how well they're
received, it can only match,
in my mind it can only match
the way I felt at the Ryman.
- I agree with that, yeah,
yeah, I feel that way too.
I'm just, and it, again going
out there and doing a show,
it puts everything else
we've done in perspective
because we wouldn't be
able to do it if it weren't
for the other things but I'm
grateful for the experience
because of everything you
said and also because it...
It gives us perspective that we can't have
when we just sit behind our desk.
- Yeah.
And like we say, we say
at the shows, it's like,
there's all kinds of
amazing things that have,
all the interactions that
we have with people online
are invaluable and amazing
and in volume, much greater.
There's just way more of
'em because it's the nature
of the internet but there
is just something different
about being in a room
full of Mythical Beasts.
It's like we just don't
get to experience that.
We make this podcast, we do the show,
we do these other things
and people experience it
on this regular basis and
have these special connections
and then we hear about
them retrospectively.
And that's really special
but to be in the same room
while it's all happening
and the immediate feedback,
and I feel like we've
got a very, first of all,
our audience is very
eclectic in a lot of ways
just in terms of where people are from,
their background, their ages.
There's also something very uniform
about the way people are just Mythical,
you know what I'm saying, so there's a lot
of like-minded people in the same room
who are just like connecting,
not just with us but with each other.
Being in that atmosphere is just special.
- Yeah so again I wanna thank you for,
if you've come out to one
of our shows, thank you,
and invite you if you haven't.
Check out Rhett and Link live.
All this isn't a promotion for our,
I mean it's an inadvertent promotion,
that's why I'm just
gonna, I'll plug it again.
RhettAndLinkLive.com.
I'm also, I got Jenna
to record our soundcheck
for the Merle cover with Britton.
I have that so I'm gonna
post that on the Society.
I'm gonna get that posted on the Society
so that's the soundcheck
not from the Ryman
but from D.C. 'cause we
didn't have a lot of time
to check at the Ryman so we had practice--
- Sounds good 'cause
we were still learning.
- It doesn't matter, I'll post
it there on the Society for--
- Okay so if it doesn't sound good,
it's just a little treat.
Okay, anything else that
we wanna say before I go--
- Give me a rec, man, give
us a rec, it's your turn.
- I'm gonna give a rec,
this is one of those things
that many, many months behind
when everyone was talking
about this thing but if you're like me,
you didn't see it originally
and I watched this movie on
the plane and so I'm gonna do
a rec of Bo Burnham's Eighth Grade.
For those of you who
have not taken the time
to see this movie, I
just highly recommend it.
It's just, there's something
about it that's so visceral,
like the way that he puts
you into the experience
of middle school in a way that
makes you feel uncomfortable
and I don't ever feel that
way when I watch stuff.
You know what I'm saying,
it's like, people talk about,
I can't watch that 'cause it
makes me feel uncomfortable.
And I wasn't about to stop
watching it but he's so effective
and the lead actor in
this, whatever his name is,
something Fisher, what her name is.
I don't know what her name is.
Look that up 'cause I
wanna get that right.
The lead actor, the lead
actress in Eighth Grade.
The way that, she's incredible.
She just nails it so hard and
so that's just really cool
to see somebody that
we knew from way back.
We hung out with Bo Burnham
at YouTube Live back in
2008, seven?
- Probably eight.
- And he was just a YouTuber, man.
And he goes off and writes and
directs this incredible film
so I know many of you
have probably seen it
but a lot of you, probably
more of you are like me
and you just didn't watch it
the first time it came out.
I just highly recommend it.
- What's her name?
- Elsie Fisher.
All right thanks for that rec.
- She's gonna go on and
do even bigger things.
- All right guys, thanks
for hanging out with us
and we'll speak at ya again next week.
We'll give ya another
biscuit for your ears.
- Yeah maybe next week will
be the peak of our careers.
- [Link] To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
- [Rhett] To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
- [Link] And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
- [Rhett] If you prefer
to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical best.
(electronic music)